hi guys I'm Greg Alba here's Johnny
John's birthday yesterday as a favor or
as a birthday gift like and share this
video I'm sorry I'm sweating I was on a
run I called John once I saw this truck
and I was pretty far away I got a little
exhausted yeah dr. sleep sequel to the
shine let's hope this trailer is worth
it and before we go into that I'd like
to thank everyone who has followed us
over at our patreon page we do weekly
Q&A as well as TV show reaction stream
along for many shows that includes
Supernatural John did all of Mike
Flanagan haunting a hill house that's
what we're promoting it's today Gotham
attack on Titan my hero academia Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood one punch
man I'm sure I missed some Cobra season
two some of those shows have reaction
highlights included as well those are
one punch man my hero academia attack on
Titan supernatural and Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood
this looks like a Mike Flanagan
[Laughter]
Oh
okay
[Music]
cool
hmm imagine with me
hey listen to me no one's home replace
the dark place there are some people I
guess they died girl when I was a kid I
bumped into these things
[Music]
no no magic i-i was called at the
shining
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
[Music]
I loved every time we saw an image of
the shining yeah that nostalgia in there
I love nostalgia whoo well that was cool
that's a good trailer that's a really
good that's a really good trailer
especially because dr. sleep for those
who haven't read the book like myself
but you know I follow movie news so once
I saw dr. sleep was like I didn't
trailer sequel is here I knew that but I
know a lot of audiences won't instantly
know that
so this trailer did a really good job at
making it clearer without saying it's
the sequel to The Shining even though he
you know you and McGregor does say I
just called that The Shining it doesn't
say this is the shining - you know
doesn't have some like subtitle like
that so I think from a marketing
standpoint they did a really good job at
executing this and slicing in the
footage and made me wonder if they're
gonna use a lot of that footage from The
Shining in the actual movie for
flashback purposes are we gonna have
some type of CGI rendered scenes kind of
like what they did with ready player one
do you know they're gonna do something
like that I would imagine there's gonna
be some of that because a part of the
crux of the book is that you know he's
been taught to compartmentalize the
ghosts of the past in his mind basically
so I wonder if maybe they'll use some of
this old footage for brief momentary
flashbacks or something it looks like
especially there are moments where he's
exploring the carcass of the the
Overlook Stanley it's interesting with
it chapter 2 coming now we're little
boys who'd had a childhood trauma with
something supernatural and we get the
adult version of them and then
now with the other Stephen King book a
little boy has supernatural encounters
but it was a boy really traumatic now
we're getting the adult version of Danny
you know I mean I don't know they're
both they both have books but it's cool
to see that they're both being brought
to life and this does look like pure
Mike Flanagan you know I've seen
Gerald's game hush the Ouija origin of
evil and I know you've seen haunting
Hill House and a couple of those films
too so this cinematography and the mood
and the tone I'm like he's always seemed
like he's had some sort of inspiration
from Stanley Kubrick's The Shining
anyway so it just it's he's a perfect
match to helm this film absolutely oh
yeah I mean he's always great at doing
those very still in cement like yeah he
has a lot of Kubrick in his style
already and he's great at doing these
ghost stories and they're also very
personal human stories and stuff and
this seems like if you're rejoining
Danny Torrance that's got to be a
character it's got to be a guy thank you
for maintaining the grounds I ran back
here for that for desert interrupts our
video but you know Danny's got to be a
traumatised guy at least a little bit
he's coping with a lot and I'm excited
to see how Mike like Mike Flanagan seems
like these has gotten to be just the
Stephen King guy to I mean like every
Stephen King adaptation that's not it
right like it's Mike Flanagan territory
well dealing with trauma though as well
is such a reoccurring theme for Mike
Flanagan for him to 2004 say I like
about his horror movies as they're very
character-based I haven't seen haunting
a hill house yeah exactly so and I know
he directed all those episodes so having
him helm this he's just the perfect fit
he's the perfect fit for this I'm
excited for you and McGregor to have a
film that looks like it actually because
he hasn't had a hit film in a while yeah
well I like this doesn't look exactly
like The Shining like I like that it
seems yeah akin to the universe but it
isn't like he's just gonna go back and
do the same things just dad like I like
that you have this weird cult element
and there are other kids out there with
the shine yeah and you've got this Rose
the Hat character who wants to basically
feed on
energy with her followers and stuff like
it's a little wild in in the sound of it
but at the same time I am very curious
about that element and in Mike
Flanagan's hands again I am very
trusting at the moment what what I
really would admire about the trailer
was that it was a more of a mood piece
trailer because you know it's easy to
conjuring this trailer or it this
trailer yeah but they didn't go for that
you know I honestly they don't really
even show you much of what the a lot of
the plot is actually gonna be about
because there is that whole cult element
that you brought up that I only just
recently heard about so there you see
certain images of it but that seems to
be more of a driving force of this
actual plot and somehow this trailer
managed to dip its toe back into the
original shining film without making me
feel like I get it I remember the
shining you know where this trailer
easily could have done that ya know it
uses it as a punctuation I thought in a
couple pretty nice ways yeah the tide
into you know the past of day it makes a
lot of sense yet because you have
Danny's past and these are gonna be
event that are very very important to
him especially I imagine as this
particular part of his journey out sets
you know and this is a story that I
genuinely think would be fascinating to
see Danny was the character who are I
mean other I'm sure we'll learn about
what happened to his mom I'm sure I
could just read the book and find out
but I'm sure we'll learn about
ultimately about how his mom dealt with
the traumas that they went through but
that was traumatic so it just makes
sense that he wouldn't grow up and be
all happy it was it was a dr. sleep mean
exactly I don't know what the play on
that is of the title just yet but it
seems like people are responding
positively to this trailer and there's a
lot of that like a lot of this creepy
imagery just blend so well with Stephen
King meets Mike Flanagan awesome guys
awesome possum lady blossom are you
excited for dr. sleep leave your
thoughts in the comments below you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell if you like this video
hit like buttons all around
and check us out on patreon last but not
least you know like ensure this video is
gift to John which internally becomes a
gift to me to gifts
you